what is the best way to learn there are
three ways that you could learn a lot of
people are smart that they're not wise
wisdom is something completely different
instead of everybody else they're
thinking the idea is that learning about
it I know that I know that I know that
no you want I ask how can I use it how
can I use their Juanes or get a mentor
what's up belief Nations Evan I believe
in you and this channel is designed to
be a part of your daily success routine
so today let's learn from one of the
best Dan Locke and his best advice on
how to become a more effective learner
also if you want to know what Dan and
other successful entrepreneurs have to
say about building unstoppable
confidence check out my 2:54 confident
series what every day to the next 254
days I will sent you a morning video for
free to help you build your confidence
the link to join is in the description
below after you practice Marshall you
develop this natural self confidence not
cockiness but you develop this natural
self-confidence
[Music]
you
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one study success what is the best way
to learn there are three ways that you
could learn number one is learning from
yourself what I call the school of hard
knocks you're learning from your
mistakes right your figure things out
now it is good and a lot of us do that
I've made a lot of mistakes I have paid
the price through the school of hard
knocks
the problem with learning from yourself
is it costs a lot of time and it causes
a lot of money there's a great saying if
you think education is expensive try
ignorance and it's very very true
learning from yourself because most
people their awareness level is very
very low and you ever had this
experience you try something new you
make a mistake and you say to yourself
I'll never make that mistake again and
next time you make that same mistake
again
and you say to yourself no I'll never
ever make that mistake again and you
make that mistake yet again so even
though you're learning from the school
of hard knocks and learning from
yourself but really you have not learned
your lesson the second way to learn is
learning from your peers learning from
people around you your family your
friends your colleagues now which is
fine the problem with that is chances
are sometimes you don't learn or you
learn the wrong thing so let me get an
example imagine two people who both
don't know how to dance I lock them in
the room and I say hey you know what you
guys teach other how to dance I'm gonna
come back in 30 days now after 30 days
unlock the door open the door my
question to you is what they Mira
commando magically know how to dance the
answer is no because they both don't
know how to dance so how could they
teach each other it makes no sense so
learning from their peers so that
doesn't work either
the third way to learn is what I believe
the most powerful way to learn is to
learning from mentor learn from someone
who's been there and done their and
continues to do it someone who is not
just the
who are in the same level who is not
even literally more successful than you
I'm talking about someone who is
infinitely infinitely more successful
than you infinitely wiser than you
infinitely more experienced than you so
let's say you're making $50,000 a year
you don't want to learn from someone
who's making $60,000 a year you don't
even want to learn from someone's making
$100,000 to you you don't even want to
make learn from someone's making a
million dollars a year you want to live
on someone who's making ten million here
20 million year 15 million you a hundred
million dollars a year why because their
level of thinking is so much higher when
you are learning from someone like that
easily they can poll you they can they
can uplift you to a whole new level I
remember when I was in my early 20s at
the time when I first found my mentor
his level of thinking at the time was so
much higher I was making a few thousand
dollars a month a couple grand and he
said to me again I'm not gonna write a
sales letter unless I believe it's gonna
do at least a million dollars a year I
said what the yeah he said I'm not gonna
write a letter a piece a direct mail
piece unless I believe is gonna generate
a minimum of a million dollars a year it
expand my horizon now my the possibility
oh wow I'm still trying to make a few
hundred dollars with my marketing pieces
he's thinking he's not gonna even waste
his ink if it's not gonna make him at
least a million dollars a year that's
what I'm talking about so learning from
a mentor rule number two get clarity but
when it comes to reading I read a book
sometimes if I'm looking for any book
that I read I have a simple question I
want to get through what are the three
ideas that I can get from the book that
can implement right now just a sweet not
10 not 20 not 103 ideas if I could get
those three ideas from the first three
chapters I'll highlight those I would
take those and I'll put the book away
I'll put it back on the Shelf maybe
later on I'll go back there and read you
out the rest of the book
and implement some of the odd ideas but
if I got my big three that's on me
sometimes I would get those ideas in the
back of each chapter where they're
talking about action steps and summary
and resources that's awesome
sometimes I got the idea just from that
table of content if I got ripped the
table could read the table content that
gave me enough three ideas I put it away
and then it just implemented so I don't
read books it's not about accumulation I
think here's a big distinction I want
you to get one of the most powerful tool
on the ball most powerful mindset you
need to have in life on business is
clarity and clarity is power clarity is
power and what is power the power is the
ability to take action so if the more
you read the more confused that you get
it gives you less clarity it means it
takes away from your power if more
reading gives you more clarity and gives
you more ability to act that's good
that's powerful right that's a test on
the right track so there's a big
difference between information and
knowledge and knowledge to wisdom let me
explain this would gives you a lot of
clarity information is just facts data
numbers figures theories principles
that's just information there's a lot of
information on the Internet there's a
lot of information on YouTube there's a
lot of information on Google there's a
lot of information but information
itself does not help you it does not
make you richer it doesn't know does not
make you happier it does not make you
healthier it does not make you smarter
information is just information it's
like you need go to school right you're
reading you're going to class
you you're your textbook there's a lot
of information in the textbook right
that's the first stage once you gather
enough information now you're
accumulating what I call knowledge
so you get a lot of information and you
now learn about the distinctions now you
take that information you apply it or
may take that information and you you
take a test that's knowledge after the
test you know after the exam in school
oh that works so oh no that's what's the
wrong answer or I didn't pass the the
the exam or here they're the mistakes
that I got wrong well you're learning
from it right
that's accumulating your knowledge so a
lot of people they read books to acquire
information you want to be there quite
information and you wonder how come I'm
watching a lot of videos I'm learning
but my life is do the same because you
haven't convert information to knowledge
and from knowledge into experience now
how to convert knowledge into experience
so now you get you acquire some
knowledge you've got to implement on the
only way you get experience and you've
dumped a lot right you make the mistakes
you see this stuff works right now
you're getting experience you're seeing
a pattern of things goes back to the the
school example now you take enough exams
remember the class you take from like
grade 9 10 11 12 right now you're taking
of exams studying the same subject for
many years in a row now you see a
pattern okay I'm accumulating more
things I'm getting more experience of
what works and what doesn't now
experience that's much more valuable
it's more valuable than knowledge and
knowledge is more available information
so books itself is just information
information does not change your life
information doesn't change your life you
got to convert it by gathering a filter
into knowledge from knowledge now you
implement now you get to the next step
which is experience then from experience
from now you you have done it long
enough a long period of time now is
evolved into your wisdom a lot of people
are smart but they're not wise wisdom is
something completely different
okay wisdom is knowing what not to do
wisdom is knowing when you don't have to
do something so let's say enough
experience you know what this is how I'm
going to make this work these are 20
things that I could do my experience
tells me these are the 20 things I could
do to make me successful wisdom is
knowing okay 19 deeds is [ __ ] just
do this one that is the difference and
rule number three the last one before a
very special bonus clip is learn to
execute better you see most people they
let the ego get in the way of success
it's very easy you notice people's I I
know that I know that I know that what
you don't know she you do not know it
how do you know when you know something
if you don't live it you don't know it
so those three words are very very
dangerous and they destroy your
potential they destroy your success why
because the minute you say I know that
your brain shuts down
you're not listening anymore and you're
like okay I know that I don't I don't
need to listen any further you're not
paying attention so what you know it so
what that you know it it's not about
knowing it I could tell you this I am
NOT an original thinker let me just tell
it to the whole world I am NOT an
original thinker there's nothing new
about what I do everything I learned
from Napoleon Hill other successful
entrepreneurs Think and Grow Rich proven
masters from the past my mentors there
is absolutely nothing new about what I
say and about what I do
I am a synthesizer I take different
ideas I put it together the only
difference between me and everybody else
is I don't say I know that what do I say
I say I use that I use that that's a
those three words are much more powerful
than say I know that because when I use
it I own it it is mine I did instead of
everybody else
there's thinking the idea is that
learning about it I know that I know
that I know that no you want I asked how
can I use it how can I use that how can
I use that I implement the only
difference between me and everybody else
I can execute it better than most people
I use it better than most people that's
the only difference instead of you just
watching a video you watch 50 hundred
videos you don't use I can use one video
I can read one book I can take ideas and
like implement execute immediately and
execute well that's the only difference
now I've got a special bonus tip with
Dane on how to get the most out of every
event that I really think you're gonna
enjoy but before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions time to
move from just watching another video to
taking action in your life for business
and if you're feeling bold leave your
answers in the comments below here we go
question number one what do you need to
execute better on number two where do
you need more clarity and number three
who's successful you study this week
just in the last 60 days I've gone to
six different events just because I'm
always about improving myself and I love
the live environment I think nothing is
more powerful when you get out of your
environment get out of your own city and
you go somewhere and just have some
learning time some thinking time and I
always on my way to to the event on the
flight I would plan I would think about
different things I would reflect so how
do you get the most out of any seminar
and event that you go to so first of all
I look at an event and ditches just me I
think most people they go to name and
they just go there to learn meaning the
goal daily thinking is like classroom
right they have a big notebook on the
laptop they go there and they try to
take us as many as much notes as
possible and they bring home they bring
the big binder and they go home and that
becomes shell help not self help you put
a shove and you never touch it again it
becomes what I call very expensive dust
collector I don't want that to happen to
you
I want you to implement so there would I
go D then I actually I go dude man I
wear three different hats okay stay with
me three different hands this thing that
I want to get out of the event my first
hat is the connector hat
I'm going there to connect with people
because this is all relationship wealth
is created by relationships so I want to
make sure that I connect with the right
people with the players with important
people and establish those relationships
so before I go to the event
I'll have sometimes my my team just do
some research ahead of time who is
attending the event who is speaking at
the event who are the people that I want
to make sure I connect with so I would
wear my connectors hat I didn't go there
my focus is I want to connect with the
right people I want to establish those
relationships deliver what valid can I
deliver to them that's why every time I
go to the event I come home I always
bring home with a lot of new contacts
and it expands my network right
so that connectors head that's how you
get the most out of it and even any
seminar not just learning the second
thing that I do is for sure I go there
to learn but the difference is I think
most people to go native and they try to
memorize again it's bad habit from
school because in school how do you get
good grades you memorize right you take
exams but in the business world it's not
like that I go there I want ideas and
strategies that I can implement right
now so if I'm going to a two-day event
I'm not trying to understand everything
that the speakers talk about I'm trying
to I'm not trying to memorize that
everything that they talk about here she
talks about that's it that's crazy I'm
trying to get a feel elegant the key
word it's elegant ideas I can implement
what I believe is if I bring the ideas
home and bring the strategies home if I
don't implement those with Dean listen
to me within 30 days is not gonna happen
you come home you get busy again
business life happens now you forget
about it and then you're like arm you
know what I'm gonna
look into it later guess what you never
look into it again ever
so the way I did to build momentum while
I'm at the event with my team they would
know at the event we're implementing I
learned to say you know what let's do it
the guy is talking on stage I am doing
stuff on sin even let's do this let's
implement lunchtime dinner we're
implementing and we're implementing even
before the flight home by the time we're
home like it's things with just building
momentum so it's not just much about
learning it's our implementation the
third hat that I wear so the first hat
connector the second hat that I wear it
just as a student as a learner right the
third is then I wear what I call the
promoters or slash speakers and now I'm
learning so imagine me I'm going to any
conference you meet me a conference you
see I have two set of books now two sets
of files if I'm taking notes with my
cell phone I'm one nook it's what I'm
learning from the speaker another file
that open is what are they doing how are
they how are they delivering their story
how they do delivering their speech how
they are setting up the event how's the
staff trained what's the flow right what
are things I could learn from what they
how they do it how they do it right not
just what they say or their speaker the
way he uses a story that's fascinating
the way he sells that's very interesting
the way they set the room the light and
and the whole experience or the
after-dinner although that's fascinating
I take a lot of notes on just how they
run the event and the speakers and all
of that so that's my speaker or
promoters head hi this is Dan Locke if
you're a fan of Evans work if you want
to know exactly how the model my success
I want to invite you to join me for a
special online training all you have to
do is click on a link below you can join
me for absolutely no charge so click a
link below and I will see you in class
if you want more day lock to the top ten
rules video I made on him the link is
right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there
why do you think people watch reality TV
you know what I thought my life is a
mess
look at these people on TV instantly if
you better buy yourself